hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
I'm Daniel and this is the first video
from our new Fitness series called male
body transformation from fat to fit so
we're gonna make a couple of videos to
help you lose weight in twelve weeks so
if you want to transform your body and
get back into shape we want you to join
us today and to make this more effective
I got somebody that can do this with you
someone that you can identify with his
name is Hannah and he's my brother hey
guys so we're gonna share with you he's
workouts he's diet struggles and
triumphs as well of course yeah because
we know sometimes life can just be
hectic and it's hard to maintain a
healthy lifestyle but I'm also very busy
and you're also very busy right yeah you
know I've got five wives five kids not
just getting one wife five kids the two
of them is twins
[Music]
all right so why did you decide to do
this buttock transformation well
honestly I'm fat
well honestly I think there's a couple
of reasons first one is first thing I
think is doing it for my wife you know
give me a little something something to
look at second thing I think is more
focus for the kids
I mean running around with em on the way
up on the sports poodles and so on
not feeling awkward uncomfortable doing
it the third thing is energy I think
just more having more energy I think we
all can remember
I mean having that unlimited almost
energy when you were younger and these
days I mean just feel trained so and
that affects performance at the office
and of course in that interns affects
what you're doing at home and and of
course I'm not even talking about off
the work just getting home and flying
other kids so I'm just having the energy
for back side yeah I think there's a lot
of people that can identify with you on
this but I hate to make this challenge
even more interesting take it to another
level we are going to enter handl into a
competition that's held by USM the
competition is called the US and body
makeover challenge now there's a couple
of rules that you have to follow so what
you share the rules with them yeah
there's not too many of them I think
that three major ones or well first off
its 12-week things so from start to
finish
only after 12 weeks to do it then of
course second thing is you need to take
photos beforehand before after practice
there once before ones you need to take
with a koala newspaper which kind of
displays the dike there and so I'm for
just bulletproof and the third one is do
those specific and they don't really
want you to use supplements and so on
from other companies so they only wants
you to supplement something using brand
that's that's the major thing - okay so
just so you know this is not a sponsored
video from us and I like MuscleTech for
example we're going to add
you other options for your individual
description that you can check out as
well alright now this first video is all
about preparing you for this 12-week
transformation period so hurry let's
share with them how we prepared you for
this so that they can get ready for it
as well now there's five things that you
need to look at right yeah yeah the most
important one day for me is time
management you know buying off camarones
existence how do you get to time are you
fitted in so time management was for me
yeah yeah they need to look at nutrition
you need to look at the supplements the
exercises and tracking the progress
that's very very important now let's
talk about time management first right
so you need to look at your schedule to
kind of see what time of day would be
the best from you to go and work out and
what we discussed also a little bit of
the time management things but what what
time is the best for you to go and work
out yeah so I think the first one is
early in the morning before breakfast
really get in there and start exercising
so that you can really get the
metabolism going and so on but that's
for me if you guys can't Mike early
morning before work is test I worked
like really earlier 3 o'clock in the
morning then we'll put it in that works
we hmm ok and you also need to plan how
many days you'll be able to exercise it
for how long so how how many days a week
do you plan to exercise it for how long
yeah so I need to do 6 days at least not
guys keep on there we need one day to to
rest as well yeah so 6 days and each day
I plan for around hour and a half to two
hours so really get in the engines well
try to win this thing yeah
[Music]
all right so let's talk about the
exercises the workout routine so why
don't we do to prepare for that
well I joined the gym you guys don't
have to you can follow along with what
we're doing the frittata mmm do the
exercises for me yeah you can you guys
can check out some of the videos I have
some home workouts for you as well I'll
link it for you in the video description
sorry I interrupted you yeah not yeah no
I actually watch some of the videos
don't try to do the advanced ones first
if you're at my level all right also
created the workout routine which you
can follow what we said we'll also keep
on updating this routine and so on and
keep it current as we progress yeah and
yeah and the other thing is of course
that we did for preparing for gym and so
on is some gym workout gear yeah yeah
we've got a bag just so you can get all
your stuff in the back gym towel because
you will be sweating a lot
water bottle you know just so you keep
hydrated what else
Oh music get a nice playlist going just
so you put it in and you just focus
working out and then gym clothes yeah so
some good still got some gym clothes in
my closet that doesn't fit so I'm just
gonna wear for the first couple of weeks
whatever I can find
and fit and so on and also that I'll
probably get some proper clothes and so
on yeah okay also some gloves you know
if you guys want to UM for me I like it
because it supports my wrists and it
also helps me not to get any blisters so
you can look into that
[Music]
so the nutrition part getting ready for
the nutrition what we kind of did is we
got the kitchen full of healthy food
because eating healthy is a lot more
important than exercise right honey
yeah well like this fight get fit in the
gym but you lose whites in the kitchen
so yeah that's true
just remember that we will be focusing
on hardcore weight loss so we're gonna
do having this nutrition plan a little
bit different but we'll add everything
for you in a video description down
below now if you have no clue of really
what to eat what is healthy I have made
the video about male-model
diet plan it just gives you a basic
guide of what is healthy what you can
eat what not to eat so have a look at it
you can watch it off to this video and a
lot of freedom video description now
let's move on
[Music]
all right supplements now you don't need
to use supplements but we are going to
her new he's gonna use it for the
competition as well because it will just
give him that advantage because if you
use the right kind of supplements it
will just really boost you with losing
weight and just gaining that muscle yeah
so I already got all my supplements
ready for the challenge I can only use
usm products but you guys can use your
favorite brand yeah yeah I'll also add
my favorites for you in the video
description that really works so you can
check those up now let's move on
alright so tracking the progress it's
very very important to track your
progress and we gonna do the same
especially for the competition we're
gonna do a little bit differently how
are we gonna track the progress for the
competition yeah so what we need to do
is every first day of the week we need
to do white we need to do measurements
we like body fat percentage and photos
right and some photos
yeah photos you guys can do it at home
as well the before photos and the after
photos so interesting to see how you've
changed over this whole period of time
so do that at home alright are you ready
I'm ready all right guys are you ready
well get ready because of the next video
we're gonna kick off this whole body
transformation and we're gonna share
with you a harness workout routine and
diet plan so see you in the next video
Cheers are you ready
Commission okay so how no lawyers
neither say we're going wrong it'll be a
very important transformation all right
[Music]
[Laughter]
Jeff surrett that's a wrap
[Music]
you
[Music]